biggest misconception is that science
has ever settled I think the public has
that to their dismay because believing
that science is settled is antithetical
to science think about it Dave if gal
came along and said well Aristotle was a
scientist he's very smart I'll just
accept that there are only four elements
instead of you know 114 or that heavy
Things Fall faster than light things all
these things he could have verified by
the way but he didn't actually go and do
that but Galilei would never have come
up with the laws of initial laws of
Relativity same with Newton Einstein
because well Newton is a genius I can't
outdo Newton as he often looked up to
him so therefore as Richard Feynman the
great Nobel Laureate of the 20th century
said science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts otherwise you'd
have no motivation to ever modify refine
and improve upon who or what came before
you